-Hey, everybody.
Welcome to Corrections.
Week, April 26th?
I think that's right.
I wanna start by just
clarifying.
Some people in the comments of
these think that
I'm getting upset by the
corrections, and I am not upset.
I love the fact that we have a
back and forth,
and, again,
you are helping me make the show
what we were
aiming for it to be,
which is without error.
So if I ever come off
as mad at all,
that is an error on my part.
So the first one we had is las
week I said that this was
a digital exclusive,
and that digital exclusive
was a fancy word meaning not
good enough for TV.
A bunch of people pointed out to
me that digital exclusive
is not a fancy word,
because it's two words.
It's two words like
"really guys"
or "[bleep] off."
[ Laughter ]
And, again,
I'm just happy to have...
We had a Mario joke,
a Super Mario joke.
We said Mario bumps his head
and a mushroom comes out.
He hits his head on a brick,
a bunch of people said
he punches the brick.
We should've known better.
Substantive is a word that I
often pronounce on the sho
as sub-stan-tive.
I've made that mistake before,
and yet Sal keeps putting it in.
No thesauruses at the
Gentile House.
And I know, as soon as I say it,
I know I've said it wrong.
Not because it sounds wrong to
me,
but because I hear Alex Baze
our head writer,
makes this noise --
[ Growls ]
[ Laughter ]
Like a bear that got woken u
from hibernating too early
Somali-eh, I said Somali-e
in last week's Corrections
Somal-yay -- I added an extr
syllable, I said it wrong.
You know what,
if you want to do these.
-I'm saving you a step.
-Somal-yay. That'd be helpful.
This is embarrassing for me to
get it wrong
because my mother was a middle
school French teacher
and every night before dinne
she would make my brother and
drink a full bottle of wine.
We mentioned, we were talking in
last night's Closer Look,
about Donald Trump said the Fo
con factory, in Wisconsin,
was going to be the eighth
wonder of the world.
That sent us down a path where
we started talking about
the other wonders of the world
Basically, did a bit where Trump
said he met Shah Jahan
who commissioned the Taj Mahal
at Studio 54 in 1986.
And someone wrote to me,
"Studio 54 closed in 1980.
Now, the best part about that,
is that Shah Jahan died in 1666.
[ Laughter ]
But that wasn't important.
Because I get the sense yo
would say,
"Well, Shah Jahan couldn't hav
been there.
It's like, everybody was there
Bianca Jagger was there.
Liza Minnelli, Paul Revere
Shoemaker, you were living
did you ever try to --
did you ever try to
go to Studio 54?
-No, you see how I dress.
-Yeah.
-I could.
-Yeah, I'd picture you there
Little Mikey Shoemaker
from the Bronx.
Standing out there sneering at
everybody being like,
"You think I'm not --"
See he doesn't talk.
He doesn't want to be on camer
so I can tell you how he talks
[ As Shoemaker ] You don't think
I'm too good for you guys?
I'm Mikey Shoemaker
from the Bronx!
I'll be back one day.
You're gonna be gone!
[ Light laughter ]
I mean, I work at
30 Rockefeller Plaza!
Cock of the Rock!
[ Normal voice ] I was talking
about Wisconsin
and I said, I referred to
supermarket in Wisconsin
as a "Kroger's," it is not
plural, it is "Kroger."
And there are no Kroger --
now I don't know how to say...
This is like "Lego" again.
There are no Kroger blocks
in Wisconsin.
They're -- someone said, "Yo
should've said Piggly Wiggly."
But, Piggly Wiggly is owned by
Kroger's.
And I only refer to companie
as their parent companies.
That's just my style.
You know who has really good
frozen yogurt?
Mrs. Fields.
And you might think they don't
have frozen yogurt.
They bought TCBY.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of, did you hear,
that we are getting our ow
Ben & Jerry's flavor?
-No.
-Neither did I.
[ Laughter ]
Neither did I.
Feels like
it should've happened.
And you know what bothers me
I'll tell you why
it hasn't happened.
They're a [Bleep]
Vermont company.
And I'm from New Hampshire
And this just them looking dow
their nose.
So classically Vermont.
They would never give
an ice cream flavor
to a New Hampshire kid --
A hard-working --
Someone from Pyongyang would get
it before New Hampshire.
Kim Jong-chill.
[ Laughter ]
I mean what would they even call
it, A Closer Lick?
[ Laughter ]
You don't --
they couldn't call it that
That sounds like [Laughs] that
sounds like an ice cream
a guy would keep
in a trench coat.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, kids.
You guys like dairy?
Time for A Closer --
[ Laughs ]
Um...Alright.
Some people don't like
the Vince Vaughn impression.
Someone said it sounds lik
Jeff Goldblum.
You're wrong.
Two completely different -
One is like "Buddy --"
[ Laughter ]
[ As Jeff ] Jeff Goldblum is u
here. Oh, hi. Yes, yes, yes.
[ As Vince ] Buddy, I'm down
here. I'm not up there.
[ As Jeff ] Oh. Yes.
[ As Vince ]
See? totally different.
[ Laughter ]
I mean this guy is a scientist
he's amaz-- he knows everything.
[ Jeff ] Oh, oh thank you.
Do you see
what's happening here?
[ Normal voice ] With that said,
I want to give people
a chance to officially mak
themselves heard
in the Vince Vaughn impression
So, please go to
@seacaptainpolls, on Twitter
and you will be able to vote
and you'll be able to say
Seth's Vince Vaughn impression
should either be kicked to
the curb
or 'tis the sweetest herb.
[ Laughs ]
Pharaoh, I said Pharaoh mean
"king" somebody told me
it means "great house."
That's pretty good.
So if your friends ever move and
have you over,
you can walk in and say,
"Pharaoh!"
[ Laughter ]
We, we really stepped in i
the other day.
I don't think we've ever
done anything
that's received more
corrections then saying
that an Icelandic gnome woul
threaten to steal
your fermented whale meat.
Immediately, I mean, we
obviously have a very --
a much higher Icelandic
viewership
than we ever could've expected
Someone said, "First of all,
it's not Icelandic gnomes
it's trolls and it's not shark
meat it's --"
sorry they said, "it's not whale
meat, it's shark meat."
Imagine living in a countr
where you would have to say to
someone, "Um, it's not gnomes,
and whale meat.
It's trolls and shark meat."
Then I realized I had put no
thought into what
an Icelandic gnome
would talk like.
And I definitely used
an Irish voice.
And then said that I was a
Irish troll who had a visa
A lot of people pointed out yo
don't need a visa
to go from Ireland to Iceland.
But I think this was
a working gnome.
I do think he would need som
sort of working permit.
A lot of people also said
it's okay to have
an Irish accent
for Icelandic people,
because the Norse, the Norsemen,
the Vikings brought over
a lot of Irish people in the
early days of Iceland to work.
And they were, and again, I only
ever read Wikipedia.
From what I read, they were no
that nice about it.
[ Laughter ]
I do not get the sense that he
Vikings set up
a job fair tent in Ireland
But I should clarify,
it would be an Icelandic troll
not an Irish troll.
An Irish troll would be someon
who would go on YouTube
and in the comments say,
[Irish accent] "digital
exclusive" is two words.
[ Normal voice ]
So, pretty good week overall
And, as always,
I want everyone to think about
what they've done
and how they've done it.
I'm gonna try to be better
I want you to try to be better
Shoemaker's a lost cause.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Shoemaker ] Oh!
Studio 54 is no good for you
Mikey Shoemaker!
Oh, but you'll let in
Jack the Ripper.
Alex...
I want you to keep the camer
going for the next hour.